kim kardashian filed for divorce from
kanye west
after six years of marriage back in
february
now a source tells e.t she's starting to
feel like herself again
in life what i've learned is you just
kind of have to go with
it e.t source adds that kim is in a
quote great headspace
and moving on from this chapter in her
life
kim is really focused on her family and
has been with the kids the majority of
the time
having kids is just there's no way to
describe it but it's a lot
the source says kim and the kids enjoy
doing outdoor activities together
and spend a lot of time with their
cousins
quote kim loves keeping them busy
creative and
on the go that's all i really need e.t
source notes that kim is quote
continuing to be a great mom
and focusing on work she has a ton of
upcoming projects that she is super
excited about
her life is definitely on the upswing
at the end of the day life is about
being happy
as for that family time on thursday she
posted
this snap lounging by the pool with her
mom kris jenner
and her sister kylie jenner the caption
family forever i feel like we are so
blessed to have the best support system
and the best family
to really just support each other no
matter what we're going through
she's also been posting some
over-the-top adorable pics of her kids
as well as her nieces and nephews it's
always so much fun
so it seems like kim is taking her
famous momager's advice
i've taught my kids from day one you
know family's everything
the kardashian matriarch recently opened
up about her personal experience with
divorce
amid her daughter's split from the
rapper telling wall street journal
magazines the one
that the kids come first quote i think
if you keep that in the front of your
mind
and know that they are going to get you
through that the love is going to get
you through
no matter how much you're hurting